going back to the Trump and the Santa's
concept so you know you talked about hey
you know you're going to win by 15. I
think six or seven right he wins by 20.
20. what are you talking about his
speech he was on fire yeah he said look
I just want to say when I first won I
won and many of you didn't vote for me
the first time those of you who have now
voted for me I want to tell you thank
you for trusting me to vote me in right
I mean there's an emotional connection
now with Miami-Dade yeah he's talking
about them to support you so so I think
that the difference is
desantis's personality doesn't allow for
blind spots everybody has them no matter
how paranoid you are you have blind
spots Trump's personality creates many
blind spots and and the tough part is
you know I I don't know if Trump's
asking what do you think like okay so I
don't know if Melania is talking to him
late at night I don't know if ivanka's
talking to him I don't know if junior is
definitely not going to be saying hey
you know I think it's DeSantis he would
never ever say that it's kind of like
Junior telling his father Gotti Hey Dad
I think it's time for somebody else to
it's just not going to happen that
mindset's not going to be there however
you know everybody thinks they know
uh how Trump thinks everybody thinks
they understand this guy everyone's like
oh let me here's what I would do if I
was Trump you
you haven't been in before 77 years you
don't know what his mom told him when he
was 12 years old son never let anybody
you don't know what his dad told him
when he was eight years old and for him
to throw in the towel as a method of
being disloyal to his parents you don't
know we don't talk about those
conversations privately those are very
emotional and his loyalty is not to his
wife
I'm not talking in a marriage sense I'm
talking in a vision sense his loyalty is
not to his kids his loyalty is not to
the Republican party I feel his loyalty
is to that eight-year-old kid that 14
year old Trump who had a conversation
with a grandpa or Fred or his older
brother who became an alcoholic or
whoever it is I feel if there's anyone
he talks to privately when he's praying
or he's talking to God or he's doing
anything I think he's talking to his
parents he's talking to his you know hey
Mom what do you think I should do hey
Dad what do you think I think those are
the types of conversation as weird as it
sounds I don't think he's calling
regular people saying what do you think
we should be doing now I did talk to
Giuliani when we were at his house and
we were doing the interview for Mafia
States of America which by the way today
Rolling Stones did an article on these
oh yeah it's it's enrollment by the way
I think it's the one year anniversary
coming up right now it could be yeah it
could be but yeah you're right
we're sitting there with Rudy and you
know we talked Trump and Rudy says that
you know him and Trump had conversation
and he says look if I if you notice I'm
being unhealthy and I can't talk I'm not
the same communicator and I'm sounding
like Biden tell me to stop I'll stop
okay Rudy said that's what Rudy's for
you to me that that him and he doesn't
know you meaning like you're not a
confidant with him no no Rudy said to me
that Trump told them
he's telling you this yeah by the way if
I start battling tell me Trump told me
wow
said to Rudy hey so here's you know so I
think I don't see Rudy you know it was a
three and a half hour interview it's a
four hour interview we sat there in his
living room we're done this is by the
way this is this is a week after they
took the stuff out of his uh FBI came in
so it's like at the time when this was
taking place and uh so if he says that
to Rudy that means there's a few people
that yeah maybe there's a few people
there but here's the other thing that we
have to we can't forget I I think you
know I've been running a sales
organization for 21 years
the mistake I made early on as in my 20s
and my early 30s I picked my killers and
my rabbits too early just because I like
their personality or I like how they
were or I liked and I'm like yeah but
that guy's too quiet
yeah but that guy is not as fired up as
yeah but that guy's a better speaker
than this guy there was a guy named Jose
it was a quiet guy
nobody backed on Jose when I first
started my own insurance company crazy
story September 23rd I had 52 agents
that were working with me directly
I told him I said guys you can pick and
choose these seven people you can work
with okay these seven people choose to
work with any of these seven people you
get to pick and choose and come and tell
me because now that I'm running a
company I can't be working with you guys
directly I have to do operations
there's this guy named Jose okay and his
wife Marlene do you know how many people
picked him zero do you know today his
business his agency does 40 to 50
million a year more than anybody that
was in that room and more than anybody
that's ever been with us so meaning you
can't pick your rabbit's tour you can't
pick a person saying this is a long race
A lot can happen the next year and a
half we don't know what's going to be
taking place we don't know what's going
to happen to Arizona if Kerry Lake wins
Arizona okay and let's just say Nevada
what's the guy's last name let's say he
wins it let's say you know he was
desantis's roommate in college did he
did not know that really yeah very
interesting yeah so if he win if they
win 51 51 49 Senate say that happens
it's not likely it's going to happen
well let's just say it does happen
Walker wins you know the runoff in
December let's say Nevada wins and let's
say Carrie Lake wins Trump can say I had
a victory so you know there is that part
where he can say carries my person Kerry
said my favorite person in the world my
second favorite person in the world is
my husband my first favorite person you
saw what yeah and she's a very much of a
if if Trump is here DeSantis has seen
the way they handle issues they're both
direct I think Kerry's here yeah I don't
think she's here I don't think she's
here I think she's here she'll call
people out so it's still too early you
know the season you know you everybody
is about you know in NFL they say who's
going to win the Super Bowl whoever
stays healthy when the playoffs start
the playoffs hasn't started yet for
presidency you don't know what issue is
going to come out with the sentence you
don't know what's going to come out with
Biden you don't know what's going to
come out with Newsome you don't know
what's going to come out with Trump
trump we still have a lot of time you
know what's going to take place so with
all the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetaining
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
or black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody